hi everyone my name is Dylan I'm an
algorithm developer at trickle and I'm
really excited to be here I want to tell
you today about a project that I've been
working on which actually started on my
first day at wiggle when I came to my
boss and I asked what am I going to be
working on and I thought he was just
going to give me a small irrelevant task
and he said well you have to create
knowledge of all the product types in
the world and I'm thinking okay that
doesn't sound small and it really isn't
and so after a while I'm here to tell
you about trickle and about my project
so our our mission integral is to
connect shoppers to the product they
want to buy through a technology that
understands them we have a few products
at wiggle we have a search enhancement
product we have catalog enrichment
products and we also have a super cool
voice app so you can imagine going
around your house saying oh no I forgot
to buy milk and it will be your phone
will apply edit your favorite kind of
milk to the cart
what so I think that's pretty cool and
forward and what's common to all these
products is that they all require two
things they require natural language
analyser which understand the different
parts of the language and I will not be
talking about that part today but the
second thing that we need is knowledge
which is represented as the universal
product ontology now if you don't
understand what I mean by knowledge or
ontology that's okay cuz I'm going to
explain that right now so our
intelligent wigle includes a few things
the first one is the knowledge of
product types and what I mean by that if
you have two products then if they are
interchangeable then it means they
belong to the same product type let me
give an example let's say I go to the
supermarket and I want to buy Dijon
mustard but they just ran out of it so I
might be disappointed but I guess I'll
just go ahead and buy your American
mastered instead so that means that they
both belong to the same product type
they're both mustard now what's a little
bit more complex is that they
different product types can help
relations between them so our mustard
can have a certain relationship with the
mustard spice as humans it's kind of
intuitive to us to think well they
probably share the same main ingredient
they might have a similar flavor and on
the other hand the mustard can have some
kind of other relationship with the
ketchup they're both condiments they can
be used for the same purpose mainly so
they have that relationship and they
have a whole other relationship with a
mustard spice so this is where it gets a
little bit tricky and for us again as
humans it's pretty intuitive but for a
computer it's going to be much more
complicated the third part is properties
so my mustard can have can come in
different packages can come in a jar can
come in a bottle can have different
sizes can come from different brands and
the fourth part which is also a little
bit tricky with constraints because if I
have a yellow mustard and I have a brown
mustard then you might be able to think
okay let's combine the knowledge of
color with the knowledge of mustard but
actually we cannot do that because there
is no such thing as the green mustard or
a blue mustard so we have to constrain
that in a way and we also have to know
that a yellow mustard is exactly the
same thing as an American master and
well I just spent the last few minutes
talking about mustard but there are
thousands of other product types in the
world and each one of them has just as
many properties and constraints and
relations with other product types so by
now you're probably thinking okay this
might be complicated and this is where I
come in
well my goal in a project is to automate
the process of knowledge generation and
I'm going to be doing that by following
users logic all right I want to create
knowledge in the way people actually
searching for
so if tomato is actually a fruit I might
not want to create that kind of
knowledge because people don't search
that way and another important thing is
that I want to keep human in the loop we
have a very intelligent very talented
domain experts in Twitter and I want to
keep them in the process because I don't
think I can reach their level of
understanding and there
of building the knowledge that's why I
want to create suggestions for product
types based on user data and I want to
give these suggestions to our domain
experts in Twitter
and the last assumption the last
guideline which I'm going to go back to
it later is that it's going to be easier
for a person to split prototype than to
join them so if our domain experts have
to look at all the different product
types and then think maybe this is like
this maybe I should connect them it's
going to take them longer than just
looking at a single product type and
maybe need to split it and I will go
back to it
alright so how how are we going to do it
how are we going to create that kind of
knowledge it's complicated
so I have four main steps in my
algorithm the first one will be to
create a graph containing many many
products then I'm going to embed the
graphs I'm going to assign every node a
vector and I'm going to foster it and
give it a name every cluster so you can
think of a huge huge graph containing
probably hopefully all the different
products in the world and then I just
want to split that graph into the
different product types I want to say
this part of the graph is a cucumber
this part of the graph is a tomato and
hopefully it will work
alright so let's dive into each one of
these steps alright so like all good
things in life my algorithm starts with
a graph and the first information that
and my graph has nodes which are curries
and products and it also has edges
connecting them and the first piece of
information which I'm putting in the
graph is real users click and so if
someone looked for fella and I clicked
on the product then I'm making that
connection and here the thickness of the
line indicates the number of people that
have made this click all right so if the
line is think it means that many many
people clicked on the product after
searching that query and write the
second piece of information that are
putting in my graph
with results from search engines so in
Twitter we created automatically many
many queries that went to search engines
and we saw what products were getting in
return so I'm also putting that in the
graph
I'm also connecting products which are
in the same category in the website and
I'm going to connect queries based on
external autologous so if I have an
external authority which told me that
feta and Brie are both types of cheese
then I'm making this connection and at
this point you might ask yourself well
if you have an external Authority why
are you putting that much effort into
creating your own and the answer is that
it's just not fitting to our need so for
example an external authority will tell
me that tomato with the fruit but I
don't want that kind of knowledge and at
this point you might ask yourself
another question if I'm building the
graph this way
then how am I getting one big graph
containing all the products rather than
many many many small graphs each one of
a product type because you wouldn't
expect there to be a connection between
the graph between cheese and the garbage
bag right so the answer isn't I bet you
guys will all know what I mean data is
messy so in users click sometimes people
click not on the product they search for
please don't do that
and also products are in the same
category can also be kind of confusing
because we can have categories like sale
or Christmas that will contain many
types of products yeah but it's good
this is where it gets interesting
alright so actually it looks something
something like this
this is just a small small piece of my
graph and again I'm building a huge
graph of product and I want to divide
them into the different product types
now if you want to perform a clustering
algorithm to on on this quest then I
need vectors I don't need nodes I don't
need a graph I need vectors this is why
I need to embed the grass and make every
node a vector and this is where I'm
using no two back
this is a good time to pause and say
yeah thank you for their meetups because
about a year ago
my colleague was here in a meet-up and
he heard about no to back and this is
how we got the inspiration for our
project so thank you or meetups and the
good things can come out of it and back
to our and thank Kelly or of course for
his lecture and back to our algorithm so
I want to embed the graphs and turn
every node into a vector I'm going to be
doing it with no two back and the way no
two backwards is kind of cool it is
based on word embeddings so in water
bindings we're turning every word into a
vector and our input is many many many
sentences of the language so when I'm
doing it for the grass I have nodes and
I want to turn them in so vector and so
my input is going to be walks in the
grass okay so if in the language
sentence is a sequence of words then in
a grass walk is a sequence of nodes as
you can see here now since I'm not going
to be sampling all the works in the
grass because you've seen how big the
graph is I am going to sample the walks
and so the way I example the walks is
crucial for the output of the algorithm
and I can sample the walks in a more
outgoing way or more localized the way a
BFS versus DFS cannot and it can be
controlled with two parameters P and Q I
can also control the number of
dimensions they have the length of every
walk and the number of walks I takes
from every point and we actually tune
these parameters using a small tag set
all right so once we've done that we had
a graph now it's gone we have a bunch of
vectors we can cluster them that's great
and I use the DB scan algorithm I used
it because it doesn't require prior
knowledge of the number of clusters
because I don't know how many product
lies I'm going to get and what it does
require is two parameters the maximal
distance between two points in order for
them to be in the same cluster and the
minimum number of points per cluster to
be considered a cluster
and all the points which do not answer
these criteria are just being classified
as outliers all right so I got my
question and now I'm going to go ahead
and give each cluster a name I'm going
to be doing that by choosing the most
frequent Engram out of all of the titles
of the products and the queries in a
product type you know in the cluster and
the rest of the engrams will be used as
seen as suggestions for synonyms and my
last step is going to be to connect
product type to connect them clusters
and so I which I've giving them the same
name why am i doing that as I've
mentioned before it's going to be harder
for a person to join clusters so I want
the algorithm to try and do it instead
if I have clusters which need to be
grouped together let's give that to the
algorithm rather than the person alright
so hopefully by that point I got my
clusters which are the product types and
each one of them will contain products
queries the name and suggestions for
synonyms I think it's time we see some
examples so I ran the algorithm on the
furniture domain and I got many many
many product types as you can see if you
would have to think of all the different
types of furniture you have in your home
I'm sure you wouldn't have gotten to
that list and there are things in here
which I didn't even know existed but our
domain experts say they exist so I
believe them and what's cool is that we
were able to capture a lot of synonyms
so for example the product side table
can be called in many different names
like accent table sofa table pedestal
table I don't know and if a person had
to go and look for all these steel names
then probably would have taken a long
time but here we just got it like that
from the clustering so that's kind of
cool we also ran the algorithm on the
fashion domain and again many product
types I wouldn't have thought of them in
like a million years and we actually
found that the clustering helps us to
solve problems of disambiguation so for
example the product on your right
have many product types in its name so
it would be hard to tell what it is
exactly you can see from the picture of
it and so here we know it's a sleeper
because it got clustered together with
the rest of the Snickers cool and also
the naming algorithm turned out to be
pretty useful as well
you can see here many products and they
have different kind of name and the
algorithm decided to call them all face
wash but I think it's a good name for it
and yeah so we were able to create
knowledge at scale we took tens of
thousands of products and we grouped
them into different product types and we
were able to do it with I think we're
more than distant the percentage of
accuracy so for example in the fashion
domain we took 60,000 products and we
grouped them to 65 product types so it's
roughly a thousand products per product
type and out of these thousand products
eighty percent really belong there and I
think it's a rather big test that were
able to accomplish and hopefully I've
managed to convince you that creating
knowledge is the hard task and this is
exactly what we do at Regal where we
combine complex algorithms with human
insight and I hope you enjoy the talk
and if you have any question and be
happy to answer sorry towards and the
data will our data was queries and
products so we had we didn't know what
are the types of the product we had to
create that that understanding yeah same
balance right so that's a great question
the question was how how do we deal with
the understanding of attributes because
I mainly spoke about
understanding product types and
attributes is actually a very hard task
so well we have a few ways of dealing
with dealing with it we're currently
building um an automatic flow to deal
with it but the it's it's hard I can
tell right that's a great question how
will I deal with the new products so the
answer is that whenever I get a new set
of data which contains maybe more
products more queries and more
categories whatever I can always just
insert that to my graph and and just do
the whole algorithm or what's more yeah
yeah well it just the other one just
takes a you know like a few minutes to
to run so I can whenever I need I can
just do it again and find more product
types given any new information that I
received it takes a few minutes because
I'm separating the data two domains but
even if I wouldn't have done it it would
just take you know maximum an hour or
something you're right right yeah I
forgot to say it so thank you for asking
for the clustering algorithm the DB scan
I also tune the parameters with with a
small tagged set but we also kept like
checking the sanity of the framers it's
very crucial when for example when we
looked at the minimum points which need
to be clustered together to be
considered a group the minimum points
per group then we thought about how many
catalogs we have and how many products
we would expect for product type to
in the catalogue I mean I would expect
okay there would be one tomato in every
catalog so this is the minimum number of
points that I need per cluster so we
kept connecting it to the real problem
[Music]
so okay well I saw that in my in my
graph the the weight of the edges is
taken from the number of clicks and
actually the rest of the data which I'm
inserting is getting a rather low weight
because I want to keep I want to make
the users data as much important as it
can be because it's the most crucial
part of their data and once I'm putting
the weights inside the graph then no
tuvok's takes that into consideration
and the betting is done accordingly
because the weight of the edges is very
important for the embedding of the graph
yes okay so given a new product that we
have how is it affecting the algorithm
yeah so it really depends on how many
new products I'm putting it in the graph
because it contains the you know
hundreds of thousands of nodes so
probably one or two products will not be
much of a difference but if I'm putting
inside if I'm putting a new source of
information it has a lot of many new
products and prototypes then it can
change of course the result but we
always we check what it doesn't need to
be changed there needs to be different
are we putting a new product types are
we expecting it to be any different so
but the more data we have it's better
right so we have a random walk and
you're asking how how sensitive so I
think it really depends okay the amount
like how would I say the change in the
categories when we take different
sampling of the graph is depends very
much on where you look in the graph
because some some parts of the graphs
are more in the graph or a more dense
yes thank you are more dense and so it
will affect them a little bit less and
there are some parts of the graph where
we have maybe little information a
little bit Dana so they are very they're
very sensitive to to changing in
parameters and and these are the parts
that we always try to to improve to
putting more data to make it more robust
and to improve all the parts that are
there are not that dense as others yep
all right thank you everyone
[Applause]